[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis et de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle édition de
parlement hebdo le meilleur de la
semaine politique et parlementaire
bonjour au rayonnement de chaîner jean
marion est notre invité cette semaine et
marie noëlle lienemann bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice socialiste de paris et vice
présidente du sénat
bienvenue à vous merci et au menu cette
semaine le projet de loi asile et
immigration débattu au sénat un texte
durcit par la droite sénatoriale une
droite dont l'absence dans l'hémicycle a
été vivement dénoncée par l'opposition
tout au long des débats mardi
l'assemblée nationale a adopté le projet
de loi pénitentiaire mans
l'apprentissage la formation
professionnelle et l'assurance chômage
il se veut l'acte 2 de la rénovation du
modèle social le lendemain la ministre
était auditionné au sénat où le texte
arrivera le 10 juillet prochain
rendre la démocratie plus efficace voilà
l'objectif de la réforme de l'assemblée
nationale voulu par son président
françois de rugy
les conclusions des travaux menés par 70
députés représentant tous les groupes
politiques ont été rendus cette semaine
et il y à des sujets qui fâchent et puis
à partir du 1er juillet il faudra rouler
à 80 km heure sur les routes secondaires
mais une partie des parlementaires
tentent toujours de faire barrage à
cette mesure
une proposition de loi était examiné
dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée et un
recours a été déposé par des députés
devant le conseil d'état
mardi les sénateurs ont donc entamé
l'examen du texte asile immigration au
moment même où le président français la
chancelière allemande plaidait pour une
réponse européenne coordonnée à la crise
migratoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelques jours après l'aquarius au
moment même où le couple franco-allemand
se réunissaient les sénateurs se sont
penchés dans l'hémicycle sur le projet
loisy l'immigration un texte
profondément remanié en commission les
sénateurs les républicains ont établi un
contre-projet au texte de gérard collomb
la très controversée loi asile
immigration jugée laxiste pour la
majorité de droite au sénat les
républicains bien décidés à faire
entendre leur voix ne cachent pas leur
hostilité au texte
ils ont fait adopter une centaine
d'amendements visant entre autres à
renforcer les expulsions limiter le
regroupement familial ou réduire l'aide
médicale d'état
un durcissement du texte assumé par le
rapporteur
c'est un choix qui est que vous ne
pouvez pas avoir une immigration
régulière et un traitement de l'âge il
qu'ils soient faits dans de bonnes
conditions au profit de ceux qui doivent
en bénéficier si l'on n'est pas capable
d'avoir un discours ferme à l'égard de
ceux qui viennent régulièrement sur le
territoire et qui veulent qu'il reste et
pour les sénateurs socialistes le contre
projet du sénat et inhumain est-ce que
être plus ferme
c'est le rempart parce que s'il ya des
lois quasiment toutes les deux ans c'est
parce qu'on dit ici que pour empêcher la
montée du front national
il faut fermer il faut fermer le front
national monte et non la législation
était sans arrêt plus dur les échanges
en séance entre la droite et la gauche
sont plus que tendues les passes d'armes
s'enchaînent la droite est aussi accusé
d'être trop peu présente lors des débats
j'ai essayé de demander à mes collègues
du groupe socialiste de bien vouloir
quitter la salle pour que vous puissiez
être majoritaires les chers collègues de
la majorité
nous avons estimé pour ce qui nous
concerne que ce texte mérite et la
mobilisation de notre groupe est
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous constatons donc une
forme de blocage dans la fluidité de nos
débats je suis quand même s'est étonné
moi toujours de l'étroitesse d'esprit de
ce côté-là de l'hémicycle qui donnait
les sont effectivement de monde entier
le sénat doit voter sur l'ensemble du
texte le 26 juin prochain
une commission mixte paritaire tentera
ensuite de trouver une version commune
aux deux chambres
marie noëlle lienemann comment vous
qualifieriez
ce texte totalement réécrit à par la
droite de toute façon déjà c'était une
très mauvaise loi et elle est encore
plus mauvaise parce que c'est un
durcissement sur qui sera proche des
thèses laurent wauquiez de l'extrême
droite et on a une course à l'échalote a
essayé de rendre la france tellement
détestable pour le monde entier en
croyant que c'est ainsi qu'on va pouvoir
conjurer une immigration qui s'accroît
donc moi je trouve ça aussi très
dangereux dangereux à la fois et pas
très humain même inhumain parfois quand
je pense à la manière dont sont traités
les mineurs dans ce texte puisque les
rétentions et son possible et pour les
mineurs isolés et pour les enfants
accompagnés
il ya d'autres exemples qui ce qu'ont
donné
la réalité c'est qu'on habitue les gens
à au motif de y aurait trop de dunes et
création il y aurait trop de réfugiés
qui viendrait nous submerger on habitue
les gens à l'inhumain et pour ce soit 21
% de français estiment que la politique
française est trop laxiste en matière
minérale mais on ne cesse de le redire
ça on ne cesse de faire une loi pour
dire que les pas encore assez forte et
qu'il faut encore tous les deux ans on
ferait mieux de s'occuper d'avoir des
lois qui fonctionne de donner les moyens
moi je crois très important qu'en effet
le délai de six mois pour que les gens
puissent savoir clairement s'ils sont
demandeurs d'asile reconnus ou pas soit
tenue mais ça n'est pas au prix du non
respect du droit et par ailleurs je
crois très importantes à partir du
moment où les gens ne sont pas retenus
demandeurs d'asile tout en les traitant
humainement et correctement nous
organisions un départ pour retrouver
leur pays d'origine
enfin ça fait des lustres qu'on nous dit
la solution c'est l'aide au
développement dans les pays du sud mais
on fait quoi
l'europe on fait quoi à part baratiner
et puis après pleurer ou après fermer
nos frontières de manière totalement
irrationnel et inopérante surtout
inopérantes
donc tout ça et d'une d'une fabuleuse
hypocrisie et moi je crois que dans la
période où on voit ce qui se passe aux
etats unis
attitude de tram vis-à-vis de
l'immigration quand on voit que ça même
de notre propre europe on interdit en
hongrie aux ong de venir en aide aux
migrants qu'on respecte plus le droit de
l'indépendance de la justice en pologne
ou en hongrie et que l'union européenne
bobo tout ça c'est secondaire par
comptant les critères de convergence
pour la grèce la lega faut payer ce nom
et trébuchants ça va pas durer longtemps
et la france se doit s'honorer de tenir
sur ses principes et d'être opérationnel
genou je ne mets pas en opposition
l'efficacité et le respect scrupuleux
des principes un mot sur la manière dont
se sont déroulés les débats au sénat
cette semaine vous avez présidé vous la
séance dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi
les incidents de séance se sont
multipliées provoquée par l'absence de
sénateurs de droite pourtant majoritaire
comment vous qualifiez vous la manière
dont se sont déroulés les débats dans
l'hémicycle
c'est vrai qu'on a une grande absence de
nos collègues républicains en tout cas
c'était c'était évident hier
moi je pense que ça n'est pas simplement
une espèce de mauvaise organisation de
ce groupe qui quand même est bien huilée
dans les traditions parlementaires
je crois qu'il y à un flottement chez
une partie des électeurs des sénateurs
de droite qui quand même même sous
nicolas sarkozy avait refusé des
décisions qui aujourd'hui sont votées
par leur camp voir proposer par leur
camp donc qui quand même ne sont pas
très à l'aise et qui voit ce qui se
passe qui sentent bien qu on est pris
par cette espèce de dérive au lieu
d'être solide sur nos bases est
opérationnel dans l'action et puis il ya
il ya aussi le fait que bah ce texte
même si c'est le texte amendé du sénat
c'est d'abord le texte du gouvernement
et dirar colons qui lui en rajoute une
sauce vous parlé d'incidents science
quand vous entendez le ministre de
l'intérieur vous dire il ya des enfants
à sociaux on sait bien qu'un enfant qui
a traversé l'europe truc il est dans un
traumatisme
il n'est pas simplement victime il est
souvent est pris il peut amener et
violent il peut avoir amené des
problèmes psychiatriques
l'enfant n'est pas asocial par nature il
est désocialisée il est en difficulté et
la réponse que de lui apporter c'est une
réponse de respect de l'enfant d'abord
est de l'humanité ne voyez que tout ça
fait qu'une partie des sénateurs même
debout du camp républicain n'est pas
très à l'aise
cette semaine l'assemblée nationale a
adopté la réforme pénicaud elle est
présentée comme le volet émancipation de
la rénovation du modèle social voulu par
emmanuel macron la réforme de
l'assurance chômage de l'apprentissage
et de la formation professionnelle a été
adopté par l'assemblée nationale
l est républicain et la gauche ont voté
contre le centre s'est majoritairement
abstenu dans l'espoir que le texte soit
améliorée prochainement au sénat ce
texte arrivera au sénat dans la semaine
le 10 juillet la marie noëlle lienemann
est ce que ce sera le cas le sénat mais
il y aura ce texte
et de quelle manière les socialistes
vont améliorer d'abord j'espère que le
sénat va améliorer c'est d'abord bilan
des courses on devait avoir la grande
révolution qu'à les rendre simples la
formation professionnelle qui allait
améliorer les conditions d'accès et donc
la quantité de formation opérer en
france on n'a rien de tout ça on devait
avoir une universalité notamment pour
les travailleurs indépendants
l'indemnisation chômage bilan des
courses s'il y en a quinze mille qui
vont être travailleur indépendant qui
vont être concernés
ce sera le boudu le bout du bout on nous
expliquait aussi que ce qui ferait
faillite or est une opportunité je crois
que c'est 3000 français annonce
dérisoire que tout ça est de la poudre
aux yeux pour ce qui est des engagements
de campagne d' emmanuel macron en
revanche il ya une grande
déstabilisation du système sans qu'on
ait construit quelque chose qui fasse
adhésion entre les collectivités locales
les régions les syndicats et même le
patronat nous avons entendu
nos collègues sénateurs de 7,8 sur ce
dossier on écoute et les syndicats mais
ils sont unanimes pour dire que c'est
que c'est négatif et même le medef
alors on va me dire si les syndicats le
medef sont pas d'accord c'est que c'est
bien maintenant parce que pour réussir
la formation professionn dans ce pays il
faut que les travailleurs sociaux soit
les travailleurs le dialogue social soit
opérant et que les partenaires sociaux
soient impliqués on va partager la
grande région par exemple de voir les
cfa disparaître dans certaines régions
ah ben oui on a autour de 700 cfa qui
pourraient disparaître alors bon c'est
quand même une marchandisation
on va plus avoir un service d'intérêt
général gérés par les régions en lien
avec les chambres consulaires avec toute
une série de partenaires qu'il fallait
sans doute amélioré parce que
l'apprentissage est une voie qu'il faut
soutenir mais là ça va être le marché
mis un opérateur piloté par les branches
professionnelles alors le pilotage par
les branches professionnelles ça me fait
doucement rigoler pourquoi parce que on
ne cesse de nous dire qu'il ya trop de
branches
donc avant de donner aux branches
téléphone avant de donner aux branches
la gestion qu'on rationalise les bandes
les branches et à 600 branches
professionnelles
donc tout ça va être une pagaille sans
nom moi je d'abord je pense quand même
que l'apprentissage et de la formation
initiale
donc elle doit rester sous un pilotage
public
je n'ai absolument rien contre
l'intervention des partenaires sociaux
des branches professionnelles faut que
cet apprentissage ils collent bien aux
besoins
tout ça est vrai j'ai été vice président
de la région nord pas de calais pour la
forme professionnelle la formation
professionnelle c'est très important
qu'on colle bien aux attentes
en même temps voilà donc oui le sénat
doit obtenir que les régions soient de
mieux associer que tout ça soit beaucoup
plus progressif dans la mise en oeuvre
si on veut mieux associer les branches
professionnelles et on doit aussi
veiller à ce que la formation derrière
la réorganisation soit pas une chute des
dotations
vous savez en réalité le compte
professionnel le cpf qui remplace tout
ça va faire que chacun va avoir moins
en réalité on l'entend en tout cas vous
allez tenter de modifier ce texte au
sénat pour une nouvelle as
blé nationale cette semaine les sept
groupes de travail qui ont planché sur
la question rendu leurs travaux leur
mission rendre la démocratie plus
efficace
[Musique]
et les conclusions des sept rapports
présentés à françois de rugy font le
même constat il est nécessaire de
réformer le fonctionnement de
l'assemblée nationale le groupe de
travail sur la procédure législative
l'organisation parlementaires et les
droits de l'opposition décrit même un
système au bord de l'asphyxié mari la
bat un système à bout de souffle
c'est la conclusion que tirent les
députés à propos de l'organisation de la
semaine parlementaire trop d'amendements
débattu d'incertitude sur les ordres du
jour ou même de redondance dans le
travail en commission puis dans
l'hémicycle de juin 2012 à juin 2010 est
en séance l'assemblée nationale a été
saisie de 115 8 0 37 amendements contre
191 au bundestag en une législature
le sujet est sensible car si tous
s'accordent sur le constat les avis
divergent sur les causes
si on est en difficulté dans cette
législature du début de législature en
particulier je veux dire il forme et
responsabilités ou là où elles sont
c'est que le ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement ne fait
absolument pas le job
voilà il ya deux mois on n'avait rien à
faire dans l'hémicycle et maintenant on
est débordé il faut en tirer des leçons
sur la séance
parce que sinon c'est la thrombose pour
permettre un meilleur temps de
préparation des futurs textes de loi
jean michel clément propose donc de ne
plus siéger en soirée ni même les lundi
et vendredi le rapporteur suggère aussi
de libérer une semaine de séance sur
quatre pour permettre aux députés de se
rendre en circonscription je sais pas
comment on fait pour être toute la
semaine journée soir compris week-end à
l'assemblée dans le même temps on a le
temps de faire ce travail de terrain
donc on va diminuer le nombre de
parlementaires et on imagine qu'on va
agrandir les circonscriptions cela me
semble tout à fait mission impossible
une partie des propositions du rapport
devrait être débattue dès le 10 juillet
prochain lors de l'examen de la réforme
constitutionnelle
1 marie noëlle lienemann faut-il
améliorer la procédure parlementaire
notamment de l'assemblée le sénat
reprennent la main sur l'ordre du jour
leur ordre du jour en d'abord je pense
qu'il faut qu'on parlementarisme nos
institutions
parce que
je suis très frappé là tout le monde le
dit à des tombereaux d'abord je rappelle
que au sénat le vieux monde là on a fait
dix heures de débat supplémentaire sur
la sncf et qu'on n'est pas traumatisé et
qu'on voit quand même voir nos électeurs
et c'est pourquoi parce que dans des
institutions comme le sénat qui ont
d'autres défauts mais nous avons
beaucoup de travail en amont
en particulier on avait faim moi j'étais
pas d'accord j'ai voté contre c'était la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
mouret mais sur sur l'arrivée de la
concurrence dans les semaines cf
nos collègues de droite avec des idées
nous on a débattu donc quand on est
arrivé à nos amendements et êtes de
chaque camp de chaque groupe était déjà
un peu on avait déjà réfléchi donc on
savait sur quoi on allait mettre le
paquet et la discussion on assume on ne
se sent pas traumatiser de prendre du
temps pour avoir des grands débats
deuxièmement moi je suis je considère
que les assemblées doivent être maître
de l'organisation de leurs travaux et
tout ce qui va aimer dans la
constitution réduction du droit
d'amendement et autres 7 à l'institution
parlementaire de définir comment il est
efficient dans son travail de il faut
lui donner plus d'initiatives plus de
possibilités de contrôle et plus de
d'autonomie cugnaux japonais l'action du
gouvernement
d'abord mieux légiférer parce que moi
j'ai un certain une certaine expérience
des deux côtés ministériel et oui mais
il faut voir les lois l'aquarelle je
suis une passionnée du logement donc je
suis toutes les lois logement j'ai été
mise au jour
mais il ya des scories administrative
des trucs techniques que les trois
quarts des parlementaires voire même des
spécialistes que nous sommes il faut
qu'on soit un truc qu'on ait bien
compris tout etc
mais il faut comprendre définissent et
c'est souvent mal foutu on dit assez
bien les ordonnances vous savez que
c'est plus long de sortir une ordonnance
que doté
on aime bien de faire un rapport au
sénat les ordonnances heures plus tard
que quand c'est voté par la loi et qu'il
ya des décrets donc tout ça est du
pipeau le travail en amont est mal fait
et il ya un principe de droit qu'il faut
sans doute repenser dans notre
république qui est que vous savez qu'en
france pour beaucoup de domaines ce qui
n'est pas interdit est n'est pas permis
il faut que ce soit autorisé donc au
zeppelin de loi avec le machin peuvent
peuvent peuvent tout ça on n'a qu'à
clarifier la loi doit permettre ou
interdire et dans la zone grise entre
les deux soit il ya du réglementaire
mieux fait soi et bien il faut aussi un
peu les initiatives sur terre j'ai mieux
cette philosophie que celle qui viserait
à dire il faut adapter la loi en
fonction des territoires ou en fonction
des zones
alors je ne parle pas de territoires
d'outre-mer ou de quelques cas
particuliers mais de redonner à la loi
sa force
elle doit permettre elle doit interdire
autres sujets de la semaine marie noëlle
lienemann les parlementaires qui tentent
de freiner la limitation de la vitesse à
80 km/heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'abaissement de la vitesse à 80 km
heure sur les routes secondaires entrera
en vigueur le 1er juillet mais elle ne
passe pas auprès des élus locaux et
d'une partie des parlementaires à un
recours a été déposée cette semaine
devant le conseil d'état et une
proposition de loi contre cette mesure
était examinée à l'assemblée jeudi
soutenue par la gauche et la droite
elle a été rejetée par la majorité alice
rougerie ne pas généraliser la réduction
de vitesse de 90 à 80 km/heure c'est
l'objectif de la proposition de loi
laissez les présidents de départements
et les préfet décide et il s'agit de
faire le choix de l'appliquer avec
discernement en confiant à ceux qui
connaissent le mieux les
caractéristiques de ce réseau secondaire
le soin d'identifier les axes qui ont
aux automobilistes des conditions de
sécurité compatible avec le maintien
d'une vitesse limitée à 90 km heure car
la mesure qui le rapporteur n'est pas
adaptée et divise le pays
elle crée une fracture ville campagne
c'est la france sans métro sans trame
sans but ce qui est visé c'est la france
sans deux fois deux voies sans autoroute
sans voie rapide qui est stigmatisé
comment ne pas s'étonner que l'on puisse
rouler à 50 kilomètres à l'heure en
milieu urbain à proximité de piétons de
poucet de vélo de bus et de risque
immense et que l'on ne puisse plus
rouler à 90 kilomètres à l'heure sur une
ligne droite de campagne qui n'a jamais
connu le moindre accident division
urbain rural et bataille des chiffres
les députés de la majorité veulent
prouver l'efficacité de la mesure est
aussi désamorcer l'argument de
l'allongement du temps de parcours
les experts ont démontré une telle
mesure de réduction de vitesse sur les
routes envisagée permettrait d'épargner
entre 300 et 400 vies humaines par an
khadir une vie par jour la vérité c'est
qu'à vitesse constante sur une route de
10 km en passant de 90 km heure à 80
km/heure le trajet sera allongée de 45
secondes sur 50 km ses quatre petites
minutes
la proposition de loi a été rejetée
la réduction à 80 km/heure entrera en
vigueur le 1er juillet pour une
expérimentation de deux ans lehmann
c'est une profession là que vous auriez
pu sauter mois spontanément je suis
plutôt pour mais en même temps je
regarde les je suis plutôt une urbaine
donc mais j'ai beaucoup de ma famille
des amis qui habitent dans des zones où
pour venir au boulot tous les jours il
faut prendre sa voiture d'abord avec les
pipelines qui vont disparaître la has a
passé il y aurait donc tous ces gens là
sont en difficulté parce que en plus ils
perdent des points de permis
quand même hein et au bout d'un moment
ils sont en difficulté en akkadien oui
doivent respecter stricte 80 c'est quand
même quand vous mettez vous en voiture à
80 vous allez vous rendre compte que
c'est quand même ça vous donne
l'impression d'être un peu lent bon moi
je suis pour que cette question de la
réduction du nombre de morts et de
blessés sur la route soit une priorité
absolue mais là soyons pragmatiques
on nous dit toujours vous êtes des
idéologues mini embedone sont des
idéologues parce que la réalité c'est
qu'on pourrait très bien avoir une autre
stratégie qui est d'équiper une route
secondaire de manière opérationnelle
notamment là où on sait qu'ils naxi
d'anthologie qui est fréquente pour
qu'elles ne rendent plus possible ces
exemples et vous avez des pays entiers
qui ont fait du travail notamment même
en allemagne où les limitations de
vitesse et notre culture où vous faites
mais mettez en situation de ne pas
rendre possibles les dépassements
n'importe comment et sept élus locaux
les mois donc voilà négocions et donnant
les moyens d'aménager passé comme
toujours c'est tellement plus simple de
durcir la loi que d'aménager et dépenser
de l'argent
donc moi je crois que ce serait beaucoup
plus juste pour l'aménagement du
territoire et nos collègues et nos
habitants qui habitent dans ces secteurs
qui sont pas les plus favorisés les
trois quarts du temps de trouver des
solutions techniques et qui leur
permettent quand même de ne pas et tout
ce stress permanent du 80 qui va être un
peu difficile
allez il est temps de retrouver à
présent notre partenaire du figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jim brass et bonjour bonjour marie
noëlle lienemann vous êtes élevé cette
semaine sur twitter contre un
questionnaire qui a été envoyé par terra
nova aux militants de la république en
marche pour savoir un peu ce qui ce
qu'ils pensaient il était amené à se
prononcer sur des affirmations en disant
d'accord pas d'accord comme il ya trop
d'immigrés en france l'islam est une
menace et avec d'autres élus de gauche
dont elle conclut que la république en
marche frayer avec les thèmes de
l'extrême droite
est-ce que c'est pas un peu excessif com
comme conclusion est ce que vous n'êtes
pas allé un peu vite drôle j'ai pas dit
qui frayères j'ai dit quand même qu'on
était étonné de cela je disais qu'on
risque est quand même de voir ce qu'un
peu à façon ironique quand même j'ai dit
aujourd'hui on à maquereau et droite et
droite quand on voit ça on se demande si
on va pas voir macro et droite et
l'extrême droite
bon évidemment je ne dis pas que ma
emmanuel macron et et sur les thèses de
marine le pen
j'ai dit que l'inquiétude que j'avais
devant les propos et des du ministre de
l'intérieur et le contenu de la droite
le droit d'asile parce qu'évidemment on
va pas brutalement sur les thèses de
l'extrême droite
on y va par disons lâcheté
progressivement
oui on peut pas faire autrement il faut
savoir et de fermes il faut pas trop
d'émotion quand un littéraire et un
homme averti comme le président de la
république vous dis il faut pas faire
vos pas se laisser envahir par l'émotion
et ben oui la raison et l'émotion
s'entretiennent mutuellement
on va l'aider droite ni gauche et une
sur toute façon ça fait longtemps qu'ils
aient pu rien de bouge dans tout ce qui
fait donc à ceux de mes amis qui ont cru
qu'ils pouvaient être et droite et
gauche en sont vite revenus
bon voilà alors sur ce questionnaire ce
très révélateur parce que vous pouvez il
me dit c'est un questionnaire
sociologique
cette méthode classique qui sont
employées du sauvage il savait le plus
qu'à poser la question vous dit est ce
que l'immigration est elle un handicap
pour la france eh ben on pouvait pousser
la question pensez vous que
l'immigration est une chance pour la
france
le raciste il va dire non mais voyez
culturellement c'est la façon de tourner
la question qui ben ça compte dans un
lac qui oriente vous savez que le verbe
la manière de poser des problèmes
a déjà du sens surtout quand on est un
parti politique
donc tout ça me paraît très dangereux on
va parler un peu du parti socialiste et
le socialiste le plus visible du moment
c'est françois hollande qui enchaîne les
un rythme vraiment effréné les dédicaces
les interviews dans l'est dans les
médias est ce que c'est un 10 un
handicap pour la refondation du parti
socialiste cette omniprésence de l'ex
président vous savez françois d'abord ce
qui est bien chez françois hollande
c'est qu'ils cherchent pas pendant
qu'ils étaient outrés président de la
république tout pouvait autour de lui
les gens râlaient la fronde de ma
chambre non c'est pas grave j'ai raison
je continue eh ben il est de la même eau
continue allez hop et continue le vrai
problème moi c'est pas pour moi c'est
pas françois hollande comme je dis
change pas et je pense pas qu'il
changera ou un vrai problème pour moi
c'est le silence du parti socialise
symptomatique quand même une faiblesse
du parti et oui et là je dis et gégé ou
ce ton on a eu un congrès on pouvait
comprendre qu'avec du temps maintenant
ça va vous faire les chantiers de la
refondation de la réflexion enfin il ya
aussi une mobilisation politique à avoir
pour faire face pour faire faire reculer
emmanuel macron pour dénoncer sa
politique et pour faire des
contre-propositions
de ce point de vue la mobilisation de
mes collègues à la fois sur la loi avait
scène cf
et sur la question de l'immigration au
dans les pâles ou parlement et est une
correcte mais si le parti socialiste est
pas là pour donner de l'ampleur à la
critique montré le danger pour le
service public montrer qu'il ya d'autres
façons de régler les problèmes et ben
effectivement on est là en train de se
complaire sur coucou françois hollande
un peu près tous ont vu l'an passé
non mais c'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est l'avenir du pays et qu'est ce que
les socialistes ont à dire et donc
j'appelle olivier faure après agir à
être candidat
tête de liste aux européennes en une
seconde un jour suffit sa peine
le message est passé merci à vous merci
marie noëlle lienemann
merci à vous jim jansen riad mancini et
nous vous disions donc à la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition de
parlement hebdo
[Musique]